what's popping Sky guys it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
spoilers for episode 4 of Ahsoka coming
your way because we have got to talk
about that ending that finally blessed
us with the imagery of both Anakin
Skywalker and Ahsoka together in live
action in this video we're going to talk
about the world Between Worlds how
Ahsoka could have gotten there and
whether or not this is actually Anakin
Skywalker because I have a hunch that
one of the darkest Star Wars villains
could be lurking in the shadows so let's
get into it all together my nerd babies
alright so the world Between Worlds has
finally hit the live-action scene
bringing with it the return of Hayden
Christensen as Anakin Skywalker but what
is the world Between Worlds and how the
hell did Ahsoka even get there anyway
well we learn in the fourth season of
Star Wars Rebels that the world Between
Worlds is a pocket reality of vast
knowledge that exists outside of normal
space and time made by The Cosmic Force
like the world Between Worlds is super
dope because it allows people to walk
across the entirety of space and time
via these winding glowing Pathways
Pathways that lead to a variety of
circular and triangular gateways linked
to various planets across the cosmos
specifically planets with some type of
force temple on them like the dark force
temples on malachor and Coruscant as
well as the Jedi Temple on lothal for
example when Ezra first arrives in the
world Between Worlds and Rebels season 4
he does so after opening the portal at
the Jedi Temple on the planet lothal
that unlocks after he uses the force on
a magic mural of three Divine figures
known as the mortise Gods composed of
the daughter the father and the son this
Trinity of force gods that protect the
world between worlds are closely
associated to the life of Ahsoka Tano in
fact these mortise gods are directly
responsible for ending Ahsoka Tano's
life but also for miraculously saving
ahsoka's life twice in the past so like
I guess that makes up for the murder I
guess I don't know but anyways during
the mortise God's Arc of Clone Wars the
mortise god of the dark side known as
the sun actually strikes Ahsoka down and
kills her In Cold Blood blood kind of a
dick move but hey that's the dark side
for you and for a couple of sad moments
there was no more Ahsoka living in the
Star Wars Universe until the Light Side
goddess known as the daughter willingly
decided to selflessly transfer her life
force directly into Ahsoka so that
Ahsoka could live again but that was
just the first time the immortus God
saved ahsoka's life the second time the
mortise God saved Ahsoka from certain
death came in the form of the mortis
Trinity opening a portal up for Ezra to
the world Between Worlds so that Ezra
could be led by the daughter's trusty
Green Owl Mirai to the correct Doorway
to the Sith temple on malachor
specifically to the point in time when
Ahsoka was about to be murdered by one
Darth Vader like there would literally
be no Ahsoka TV show if Ezra did not
pull Ahsoka out of time but it also
appears that ahsoka's life may have just
been saved by the mortise Gods a third
time by the end of Ahsoka episode 4 when
she survives being thrown off of a cliff
by being transferred to the world
Between Worlds once again but this time
her old Master Anakin Skywalker is
supposedly waiting for her like what the
hell is up with that anyway like how the
hell did Ahsoka even get there and is
this actually the real Anakin Skywalker
well in my opinion the answer to how she
even got there is likely tied to one of
the last things that Ahsoka did before
she fell which is burned the out of
her hand after trying to grab onto a
star map roasting on an open witch fire
why would you do that Ahsoka that ball
is hot that's right everybody I believe
at the star map and its links to the
mortise Gods is exactly what teleported
Ahsoka to the world Between Worlds
instead of her falling to her death
especially after examining the clues
left behind in the star map pedestal
room in the Arcana ruins from episode 1.
in one of my previous Ahsoka videos
where I essentially tell you guys that
the world between the world is coming
and it did this is the happiest day of
my life
I noted that the resting place for the
star map was heavily modeled after the
mortise God Trinity imagery with the
three figures on the walls of the star
map pedestal chamber each using hand
gestures that directly reference the
left hand gestures that the Sun the
daughter and the father use on the
lothal Jedi Temple mural with one figure
having their left hand pointed to the
left like the daughter another figure
having their left hand pointed upwards
like the father and a third figure with
their hands in an enclosed position like
the sun in the center of that room where
the star map sits you can even see a
triquetra symbol on the ground a symbol
that is closely associated with
trinities in real life much like a
triquetra is used in the church to
represent the Father the Son and the
Holy Spirit all of this is in that video
I did before please check that out if
you haven't already some good stuff but
most importantly when Ahsoka listens to
the star map Stone resting place with
her Force ears you can hear Force
Whispers coming from the storm map
itself Whispers that some people on the
internet like Twitter user at Star Wars
only say sound a lot like Dr Sam
Whitworth take a listen
[Music]
while this specific person on the
internet thinks that Ahsoka is listening
to the voice of Sam whitworth's
depiction of Darth Maul because of the
overall mortise God Trinity symbolism of
the star map chamber I'm more inclined
to believe that we're actually hearing
Sam Whitmore in his role as the sun the
very mortise God who took Ahsoka Tano's
life when we first meet the sun in the
Clone Wars series during the mortise
Gods Arc the sun was obsessed with the
idea of corrupting The Chosen One Anakin
Skywalker so much so that the sun even
managed to manipulate Anakin Skywalker
to the dark side completely as the sun's
Apprentice before Palpatine even did so
in Revenge of the Sith and the sun did
this by cursing Anakin with Cosmic
knowledge the sun showed Anakin visions
of his dark future of losing Padme and
becoming the Sith monster Darth Vader
and Anakin's fear of being too weak to
stop that very future from happening is
all the sun needed to secure his new
apprentice and the sun would have
escaped with his dark Apprentice Anakin
to destroy both the Jedi and the Sith
and ruled the Galaxy together with the
power of the dark side if it wasn't for
the father's wise decision to erase the
knowledge of the future that the sun put
in Anakin's mind to make him join the
Dark Side in fear in the first place the
sun would have literally been in total
control of the chosen one that he
coveted so much if it wasn't for the
father or racing Anakin's memories but
anyways this all being said because of
the star map's connection to the mortise
Gods I believe that Ahsoka directly
grabbing onto the star map with her left
hand while it was activated seems to
have infused some Force energy from the
star map directly into ahsoka's body and
that star map energy acted as the bridge
to teleporting Ahsoka to the world
Between Worlds and Ahsoka being
teleported to the world Between Worlds
makes sense considering that while the
star map is actively projecting imagery
of the galactic map by Morgan ellsbeth
the golden sphere itself seems to
represent the very core of the Star Wars
Galaxy especially since the world
Between Worlds is the realm that
connects various planets of the Galaxy
together so it makes sense that the star
map would link to the world Between
Worlds in that way but also keep in mind
here that Ahsoka burnt her left hand
after trying to grab that star map much
like how the left hands of the mortise
gods were emphasized in both the lothal
and Arcana ruins I definitely feel that
this was intentional to symbolically
link Ahsoka to the Trinity holding the
star map on the Arcana walls but the big
question Still Remains here is this
actually Anakin Skywalker that we are
seeing in the world Between Worlds at
the end of episode 4. well it is
impossible to know 100 sure at this
point because it could honestly go one
of two ways in my opinion either that
Anakin that we see is the actual Force
ghost of Anakin Skywalker from after he
died saving Luke or this Anakin
Skywalker is a dark side generated
illusion but let's start with that first
one the reason why this could be the
Force ghost version of Anakin is because
the world Between Worlds appears to be a
manifestation of the cosmic Force itself
where all the force energies of all the
Jedi who lived live amongst the stars in
the cause Osmos like remember when Rey
looks to the Stars to ask a bunch of
dead Jedi to give her a pep talk in the
rise of Skywalker she was communicating
to the force of the cosmos otherwise
known as The Cosmic Force this is why
the world Between Worlds is just a bunch
of Pathways in the middle of a sea of
infinite stars and a bunch of
constellations so it's quite possible
that the world Between Worlds could be a
cosmic Force hub for all the past Jedi
who have become one with the force after
death and that Anakin chose to
materialize his Force ghost energies to
appear in front of an alive Ahsoka
visiting his realm of the Dead if this
is in fact the case we could very well
see a scenario where other dead Jedi
like Obi-Wan Yoda Qui-Gon Jinn or even
Kanan could potentially show up and
impart knowledge onto Ahsoka before
sending her back into the universe to
stop Morgan and balen but not shindo
Shin didn't do nothing wrong Shin is
perfect Shin is a beautiful human being
you do no fault and if they arrest her I
will speak on her behalf no reason I
just like girls who can beat me up
anyway however I'm more inclined to
believe that this Anakin Skywalker
figure that Ahsoka sees in the world
Between Worlds is not Anakin Skywalker
at all but instead a type of dark side
illusion I mean did you hear how episode
4 ended with the Darth Vader theme after
Shadows were being cast Over Anakin's
face some dark-sided is afoot
and I think that dark is
courtesy of the dark-sided mortis God
himself the Sun that son of a just
kidding he doesn't have a mother though
the sun was presumed dead after Anakin
stabbed him at the end of the mortise
Gods Arc I think that the dark side of
the force may have found a way to
preserve the sun in the mortise Gods
World Between Worlds because not only is
the dark side a gateway to unnatural
abilities like defying death but also
remember how Ezra ran into Mirai in the
world Between Worlds that owl is
strongly implied to be the living Force
manifestation of the daughter now if
that daughter-ass owl has the authority
to just hang out in the world Between
Worlds even after death then the sun
must likely be able to do the same as a
mortise God and considering that we do
hear what sounds like the voice of the
sun Whispering about the chosen one in
episode one
I would not be surprised if it was
revealed that Anakin was actually just
the sun shape-shifting himself into a
form that would disarm and manipulate
Ahsoka much like when the sun
shape-shifted into Anakin's mother in
order to manipulate him during the
mortise God's Ark but why would the sun
need to do all of this why would he need
to trick Ahsoka with her Dead Master
when he's so damn powerful well my
theory is that much like in the mortis
God's Ark the sun is trying to free
himself from a realm that he finds
himself trapped in first in the Clone
Wars he tried to escape his Homeworld of
mortis to rule the universe with Anakin
Skywalker and now in the Ahsoka show I
think that the sun needs ahsoka's help
to escape the world Between Worlds
pocket reality like Leaf of a means of a
living vessel it would basically be a
reverse situation to the last time
Ahsoka was in the world Between Worlds
and Palpatine needed a living host
inside that world Between Worlds to let
him in but this time the sun would want
to get out and since the world Between
Worlds is a realm of infinite Cosmic
Knowledge from across all time I can
definitely see the sun trying to
manipulate Ahsoka into joining the dark
side by feeding her future knowledge of
the thing that she fears the most future
War Ahsoka does not want another War to
happen but we the audience know that the
first order are coming to the Star Wars
Universe to fight another star war with
General Leia's resistance but Ahsoka
herself has no idea of these future
events so I can see the sun using the
world Between Worlds to show Ahsoka both
supreme leader snoke and kylo Ren's
coming Reigns of Terror and death to try
to get her fear and despair to lead her
to the dark side just like he did with
Anakin then if the sun could manipulate
Ahsoka into not walking away from his
fake Anakin like she did with the real
Anakin than the sun could theoretically
use Ahsoka as his Dark Side vessel to
enter the real Universe once again or
just to use her as a new Apprentice
because you gotta remember Ahsoka does
have the life energies of the daughter
living inside of her being after all and
the Sun is historically obsessed with
the daughter so I can see the sun
wanting to possess Ahsoka as a way of
possessing the daughter after she dies
but anyways that is what I believe is
happening with the world Between Worlds
and and Anakin Skywalker what did you
guys think about episode 4 and what do
you guys think is going to happen in
episode 5 let us know in the comment
section below but thank you guys so much
for watching this video you can follow
me at mastertameda on Twitter if you
guys want to see me tweet some weird
and really fun theories got a lot
of Star Wars theories lately so follow
me there if you guys want to see me
tweet a lot about Ahsoka after it comes
out but most importantly do not forget
to subscribe to heavy spoilers right now
we are breaking things down constantly
you guys do not want to miss a singular
breakdown that we are going to do doing
a lot of Ahsoka stuff I'm breaking down
a lot of Marvel stuff I got a blade
breakdown in the works for you guys so
do not forget to subscribe to heavy
spoilers today but again thanks again
for watching this video I love you guys
so so much and I'll see you guys next
time goodbye
foreign
[Music]